what is it to say that something is real
or to say that one thing is more real
than another and I think that is an
important question and I think that
question can't be decided by just
looking within any particular theory for
its particular fundamentals because what
we're asking I think I would argue when
we're asking questions about reality is
what what makes possible any and all
such intelligibility what makes possible
any possible theory that might turn out
to be true there has to be some aspect
because we take it I think that reality
in some sense corresponds to our ability
to make our claim to find our claims
true or our skills applying or a
perspectives present Etc so I I'm waving
over with that with my hand because
that's a big thorny knot but I'm trying
to pull apart I think there's
reductionism which we put aside there's
fundamentality and I will I agree with
Donald what he just said about that and
but I think we have an extra theoretic
notion which is the notion of realness